welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down
richer season 2 has just dropped its
finale and I thought I'd look at the
future to break down what could happen
next throughout this video we're going
to be talking about the stories I could
adapt and also giving all the info that
we know so far there might be some
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know then hit the road Jack Reacher and
don't you come back you son of a
now we also have a finale breakdown on
the channel right now so head over there
if you need to get caught up out the way
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into Reacher season three in
an
investigation assumptions
[Music]
kill okay Z Reacher ends with him
heading out on a bur after reuniting
with the team he left long ago where
he's heading next we just don't know but
season 3 is already in production
they're at work right now putting it
together which has been confirmed by
Rich and himself December's a season of
hot cocoa and smiles and now Reacher
that's right season two of Reacher
premieres December 15th on Prime video
you know what else December's a season
of
surprises and boy do I have a surprise
for you that's right you're on the set
of season 3 ARA right now we're
officially underway and while I can't
say much more about what we're doing now
I can share this exclusive extended clip
of season 2 hope you enjoy I'm as unw
likely want to get it released ASAP and
shooting began back in December with
typically their Productions running for
3 months reer it's not really a heavy
VFX show and they also tend to shoot on
location you see kids every time you
shoot on green screen it becomes a VFX
shot and then has to be sent off to VFX
companies however with Reacher mainly
shooting on location this isn't needed
so the time is cut down previous seasons
have shot for three months so they'll
probably be wrapped up on this around
about spring that is of course if
everything goes to plan and who knows
they may have up the budget and included
more effects lad and stuff not saying it
doesn't have effects mate not slagging
off but you know what I mean either way
reach has been such a big show for
Amazon and my guess is that they'd want
to get it out fast thus I'm predicting
an early 2025 release with it Landing
roughly around February or maybe even
earlier now as for where we go plot-wise
it's difficult to predict as the series
itself has been a bit all over the place
bad luck in trouble was actually the
11th book so setting that as the second
season you know you can't really guess
going forward in interviews richen has
said that season 3 was his favorite
story though and I ped through
interviews to find out what that was I
did cover this more on depth on our last
video so if you want to know the story
of that then head over there although
right that's right you want to know the
name
well we're
waiting well it's Die Trying Die Trying
mate which also happens to be the second
book released you could say they wanted
to get reach or die trying get reach or
die trying
again it's on the ending explained if
you want to know the story however that
hasn't been confirmed so I thought I'd
look at the other potentials that could
be coming out now as for the clip from
before there's not much to go off but we
know that it was filmed in Canada well
lots of shows end up shooting there
because it's cheaper than filming in the
US still though the GU shot in December
so the weather might affect what's going
on a copy book.com were actually nice
enough to put a list together of clues
that were dropped in the finale which
could hint to where things are going to
go the first of those was the book Tri
out which is also one of the most
popular in the series it actually
features Reacher living in a town rather
than just going out on the road the town
in itself is called Key West which put
put a little pin on it as we'll travel
back to that now it's important to point
out Key West isn't anything like Canada
um so I will discuss another option as
we get further into the video however I
think it would be a good place to start
things and be a sharp contrast from
what's come before working as a boun to
by night it is someone who shows up
looking to reite with reair and we could
possibly get a returning character who
comes from season 2 comic book.com noted
that Reacher ended up helping out Molina
who worked at the bar earlier in the
season in the finale we see her with a
brand new car and joking about sending a
friends postcards as she goes off she
says key Wester burst which again would
put her on the path back to
Reacher it also features a big villain
in Hook who I think they could cast it
as someone big and memorable there's
lots of interesting ways they could take
things to and it's one of those that's
probably easy to adap into a show just
the cable of having him actually live
somewhere would be a good way to go and
it could then explain why he never stays
too long rich and did a separate
interview with comicbook.com and also
talked about what season 3 would end up
entailing he said and we get to enjoy
richet in a new world it may not have
been anything to do with family with his
past he's just living that Adventure out
and that's kind of the direction that
we've gone and it seems to really be
working so the clues are there that
they're trying something different which
may lead to a season that we haven't
really seen before I know a lot of the
criticisms about season 2 was that it
was just more of the same from season 1
but I liked it mate so shut your bloody
mouth H but maybe they saw that early
and realized they couldn't do it for
three of them Molina going out there
could set up the events of trip wire and
it might also be someone they safer down
the line trip wire being such a big book
makes sense as well and that's
definitely something I'd like to see
them tackle now all Reacher tends to
have is a toothbrush and clothes on his
back but with his millions he could be
buying whatever he wanted may I suggest
checking out on merch store Jack which
has loads of different t-shirts hats and
hoodies right now we've got few Time
shirts one's with Kevin foggy saying
it's all connected and lots of different
franchises like Star Wars and House of
the Dragon huge thank you to everyone
who's picked one up and we really
appreciate all the support and love now
this side also brought up 61 hours which
begins with Reacher riding on the bus
crashing in the snowstorm out in South
Dakota it sees a killer getting loose
which Reacher has to track down Canada
and winter could really help bring this
to life and if they were shooting there
then that makes a lot of sense the snow
and the bus are essential to the plot
and it would create an environment the
likes of which we haven't seen before
snow can be such a cool place to have
things and it helps to add paranoid to
what's going on the thing of course used
it brilliantly and recently True
Detectives also used it too the bus is
also a great place to go with it as it
would immediately pick up with where we
left off going back to that old guy that
old guy at the end of season 2 and oh my
God the psycho killer it's it's all
starting to make sense now
I think the bus thing is a bit of a
Reacher though cuz Reacher always out on
buses it doesn't mean Jack to start off
there and it's more wiping the slight
clean so they can go where they want
however if they stick with 61 hours and
it'll become clear that they're going in
a certain direction the one following
immediately on from that is worth dying
which is also canonically its own
perfect sequel I'm guessing this is
going to get a fourth season as well so
it would be nice to get a onew punch of
having those back to back so yeah those
are my theories on it and personally I'm
still riding with Die Trying that's
purely because Allan said that was his
favorite book and that upcoming season
was his favorite story too who knows
though cuz there's a lot to adapt but I
think they'll avoid one shot and never
go back that's of course because Tom
Cruz already did them and there's lots
of other stories that the team could do
instead they probably want to carve out
their own lane and I think this Reacher
show has been pitched perfect now
obviously there's still a lot of few
times about what could be going on so if
you have your own then the comments of
for you drop them drop them below or
I'll drop you and I can't wait to hear
what you guys' ideas are please also
smash a thumbs up and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you'll get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out also just a
heads of everyone we were going to
release our 50-minute breakdown of No
Country for all men this weekend but
Paramount they've put a delay take down
on it you son of a what happens is
that they claim the video give you seven
days days to remove it and in that time
you've got to wait until it gets removed
you can then counter claim it you go
through a legal process over 14 days and
after all that gets dropped it then gets
put back up I did promise a brand that
i' drop their ad on Sunday so we might
have to end up pushing that video back
if that happens I'm going to drop back
to the feature 3 instead so keep an eye
out for that on the channel cuz it's a
really really good one for to mention
that no country won in lots of other the
breakdowns we haven't released yet so if
I'm shouting it out to go and watch it
and it's not on the channel now you know
why hopefully though we can get this
sorted but this delayed strike means it
probably won't be out until the middle
of February fingers crossed we get it
sort in time for Saturday but if we
don't then my bad on that now if you
want something else to watch then check
out our Reacher season 2 finale video
which is going to be linked on screen
right now that covers the book what
happens at the end and also lots of cool
little Easter eggs that they lace
throughout the show by the way huge
thank you for Sing to this video I'll
been your host Paul I'll see you next
time take care peace